[Applaudissements]
oh non et puis si j'ai 16 ans
j'ai eu 16 ans
voici seize ans
et de mon âge mon jeune âge je me posais
milliards lumière nos questions je me
pose des questions sur qui je suis
vraiment tu me poserait question quelles
sont les réalités de la ville des
véritables chose derrière certaines
choses je me pose beaucoup de questions
mais là dessus j'aimerais d'abord aucune
émission ainsi de vos ambitions
si dia thiam une personne ou encore à un
groupe de personnes vous y arrêter de
faire quelque chose qu'ils aient quelque
chose en quoi vous croyez plus surtout
tour aux quelque chose qu'on sait que
votre vie ne sera pas possible sans une
chose pareille dans le marais terrier ou
est-ce que vous arrêtez de faire cette
chose tu ce parce que quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un d'autre plus fous vous qui
connaissez plus que n'importe qui au
monde sinon cela ne ressemble pas arrêté
de le faire
le vin bien sûr
moi j'ai la perspective des choses et je
me dis que tout le monde
le tout le monde prédit tout le monde
doit choisir son sur un moment de
prendre soin de lui sans le meilleur et
le chemin parce que c'est là que j'ai
réussi si la asus et tout le monde aux
conditions voilà pouvoir cette vision
que je dirais
6 la russie c'est faire ce que nous
aimons être épanouie pour ce que nous
faisons j'avais un rêve un rêve d'être
avocate il ya un an
et bien sûr je me disais que pour la
beauté c'est là où je m'excuse pétrole a
enjoint et c'est là que je verrai mon
succès mais ces choix
influencé par les personnes qui m'ont
dit oui certains institutions il me
disait juste que ce métier fait bien
parce que l'univers servi par le bo est
une personne un joystick et qui se pose
beaucoup de questions sur tout et
n'importe quoi et tu cherches le
pourquoi de la preuve je me disais qu'un
point au 10 octobre au théâtre c'est un
titre la volonté mais je suis encore
mêlant small ce qui me disait tu vois
aussi à alimenter se disait jeudi à
peut-être sa raison et que constituent
les adultes qui me le disait je me
disais que comme si on les a vus il en
extérieur
donc alors j'ai consommé tu commencé à
faire est littérature concentrer un peu
plus sur 26 aux de cheval et pour être
dans un endroit où il ya plus de bulles
terrain s'ils veulent ils vont exister a
expliqué à faire bien on me dit le droit
mais passé
je me sentais comme si quelques secondes
comme si ça ne serait pas aussi quelque
chose la douma je suis plus du tout de
voir plus je voulais me sentir
aujourd'hui avant plusieurs motions sur
leur mêlée genia vibra car je ne parle
ou d'objets jeu voire plus alors j'ai
pris la mesure des choses je suis à
l'insensé matrix est actuellement suis
allé intensifie commencé à être connu il
ya plusieurs semaines je faisais
plusieurs choses à la fois les bases
physiques ces choses là dedans et ça m'a
permis d'ouvrir le voir plusieurs trucs
à barbezieux
et je vous fais comme tu me semblait
connaître
je vous en fais comme si ou marty droit
souffre mais je me sens comme si je me
sens vide sont la véritable nom à tenir
enfin la mettre là finalement final je
me sens bien je sens que je vais
ressentir tous les jours de ma vie dans
le domaine jean masson voilà chose si ça
je me dis tu ce moment là parce que ce
sentiment là vous êtes sorti mais ça me
permet d'exceller dans les choses que je
vais ce sentiment là je me sens si ce
sens ce moment là que je pense prenez
plus qu'un exemple mais cela m'a mis la
fixeuse la matica dirigeants mais
quelque chose qu'on regarde et comment
1700 consacrer son temps sont en crimée
site choisi l'allemagne aujourd'hui
génial mais dallaire la nuit il a un
avis au plus haut
en faisant droit nous vivons dans une
société où ils ont une certaine vision
cette classe de cp à 9 h 15 d'après eux
alors une femme car même si c'est
quelqu'un du voyage d'argent quelqu'un
qui a des mises au milieu de nouveau sur
quelqu'un qu'on votre toutou licence
d'après v6 pour être dans ce milieu là
si on le fait justement c'est un messie
entre mieux vous vous sentez à l'aise
quand vous sentez pour eux et j'ai même
le jaguar en fait le choix aux knicks
avec mon chien ça déjà mais miro ce plan
les choses de la meilleure manière de
grands et vous influencer plus en
faisant juste faisait peut-être
jusqu'ici jamais d'être certaines
entreprises
je suis un aliment ou même en ce moment
même le sentiment manger ou sont issus
du cycle heureuse ces sentiments que je
veux continuer à voir la magie peut-être
le futur l'endroit le contraire c'est
aussi la future de mentorat que vous
avez le temps et pour le moment où tu te
demandes suivis dans ce chemin je n'en
veux faire ce que j'aime oui jour de ma
vie lisieux influences comme ça je veux
pas que les gens se rappellent mort pour
l'argent pour chose que j'aurais et je
sois qui se rappelle aux personnes
une personne est la mieux informée
[Applaudissements]